[موسيقى]
شكرا اذا للزميل صهيب مشاهدينا ما زلنا
معكم في هذه التغطيه المستمره لتطورات
المشهد السوداني حيث تجددت قبل قليل
الاشتباكات بين شقي المكون العسكري اي
الجيش السوداني برئاسه الفريق اول عبد
الفتاح البرهان وقوات دعم السريع بقياده
محمد حمدان دبلو المعروف بحميدتي وقد سجلت
عوده الاشتباكات في محيط سلاح المهندسين
في ام درمان كما تجدد ايضا ضوي دوي
واطلاقي نار في محيط مقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه بالخرطوم وذلك واستدعوات
اقليميه ودوليه لوقف اطلاق النار وفيما
تضاربت بيانات الجانبين فيما يتعلق
بتطورات القتال وتبادل فيها اعلان السيطره
على هذا الموقع او ذاك دعت السعوديه ومصر
الى عقد اجتماع عاجل لمجلس جامعه الدول
العربيه على مستوى المندوبين غدا الاحد
لبحث الوضع في السودان
اذا مشاهدينا في هذه الاثناء نتابع هذه
الصور الحيه اذا من الخرطوم تجدد اذا
الاشتباكات وارتفاع اصوات الطلقات الناريه
ما بين الطرفين
المكون طبعا او شقي المكون العسكري الجيش
السوداني وايضا قوات الدعم السريع طبعا
كانت هذه الاشتباكات مستمره منذ عده ساعات
بعد موعد الافطار في السودان
وكانت تتصاعد بين الفينا والاخرى
لمستوى عالي جدا من التصعيد ومن ثم يسود
الهدوء الحذر المشهد بعد ذلك
معنى لا مشاهدينا من الخرطوم مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك يا سالم
معنا سالم تجددت الاشتباكات اذا كيف تبدو
الاوضاع الاداء
نعم الاشتباكات تجددت مره اخرى في الخرطوم
مقر القياده العامه للجيشه التي قال الدعم
انه يسيطر عليها في محاوله لاستعاده سيطره
الجيش على هذه المنطقه المنطقه الحيويه
بكل تاكيد وهي مقر قياده الجيش السوداني
في العاصمه الخرطوم ايضا من الاخبار التي
وردت ايضا
ان منظمه او عفوا للصليب الاحمر في
السودان دعت جميع الاطراف الى ضبط النفس
واحترام
التزاماتهم القانون الدولي الانساني اوضحت
انه يجب ان يتم تجنب المدنيه واتخاذ جميع
الاحتياطات الممكنه لتجنب اصابه المدنيه
ضمان الوصول السريع والان للسيارات
الاسعاف والعاملين في المجال الطبي كما
دعت اتخاذ كافه لتسهيل عمل المنظمات
الانسانيه طبعا نقابه الاطباء سالم قبل
قليل تتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد قتلى
الاشتباك الصوتي طلقات خلفك هل يمكن ان
تعطينا فكره حول المناطق التي تتركز فيها
الاشتباكات في هذه اللحظه
نعمل اشتباكات تتركز في مقر القياده
العامه للجيش وايضا هناك اشتباكات في
درمان بالقرب من سلاح المهندسين
تتجدد ايضا فيه الاشتباكات هذه المنطقه
الحيويه ايضا والتي تشتمل على العديد من
المناطق التي فيها مناطق عسكريه تدفع
الجيش السوداني فيها سلاح المهندسين فيها
جامعه كرري كذلك فيها السلاح الطبي كذلك
كل هذه المناطق وايضا الاكاديميات الامنيه
الاكاديميه العسكريه ايضا كليه القاده
والاركان المشتركه كل هذه في هذه المناطق
الحيويه بالنسبه للجيش السوداني في ام
درمان
بجوار او امام غرب مباشره جسر الفتحات هذه
المناطق تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات الان
المواطنون والمقيمون هنا
يتحدثوا على انه هناك
اصوات
مندافع ثقيله كذلك تسمع في تلك المنطقه
الجيش السوداني كان قد ذكر بانه على
المواطنين ان يلتزموا منازلهم لان هناك
حمله ستكون جويه لضرب كل المناطق التي
التي يتواجد فيها او تتواجد فيها قوات
الدعم السريع لكن هذه الحمله الجويه لم
تبدا حتى هذه اللحظه
طيب ماذا نتوقع في الساعات القادمه يعني
تصاعد على ما يبدو في وتيره الاشتباكات
خصوصا بعد عمليه المسح الجوي المرتقبه من
قبل قوات الجيش هل هناك معلومات يعني
المناطق التي ربما ستستهدفها الجيش كان
اعلن بانه سيتم استهداف مناطق تواجد قوات
الدعم السريع اين هي
ويعني ربما بعدها عن المناطق الماهوله ام
هي في وسطها
قالب هذه المناطق في الخرطوم هي ماهوله
بالسكان للاسف وتحيط بها مناطق السكنيه
كثيره جدا لكن تحدث الكثيرون من الشان
العسكري بان ضربات الجويه قد تكون دقيقه
بحيث انها لا تصيب المدنيين
باي شيء لكن واقع الامر الان يقول عكس ذلك
تماما ان هناك اضرار يلحقه بمدنيه هذا
الامر واضح من عدد الاصابات في المدنيين
سواء الاصابات او حتى
الذين قتلوا في هذه الاشتباكات من
المدنيين كذلك من اعيرنائيه طائشه او حتى
في منازلهم او حتى كانوا في الخارج كل هذا
الامر كان واضح في الساعات الماضيه ايضا
هذا التجدد للاشتراكات اثار ذعرا وقلقا
لدى المواطنين واضح جدا في تصرفاتهم هذا
يتزامن مع
انقطاع انهيار الكهربائي قطاع الامداد
المائي في خدمات الانترنت كل هذه الامور
تدعو الى القلق والتوتر وتدفع الى ان
الامر ما زال ما زال في محتدم ويمكن او
انه قابل للزياده حتى
طيب اذا ما زلنا مشاهدينا مع هذه الصور من
مناطق مختلفه من السودان
للاشتباكات التي حصلت على مدار هذا اليوم
في وقت سابق وايضا صور حيه الان
لمحيط مقر الجيش السوداني حيث
تتجدد هذه الاشتباكات على ما يبدو كنت
ذكرت سالم بانه ما زالت تيار الكهربائي
مقطوع هل عاد الى بعض المناطق على الاقل
التي لم التي كان مقطوعا فيها يعني ولم
يعد اليها بينما عاد لمناطق اخرى
عوده السياره الكهربائي جزئيه جدا في
مناطق محدوده جدا من العاصمه الخرطوم بمدن
بمدنها ثلاث درمان وبحري والخرطوم كذلك
غالب المدن الثلاث ينقطع عنها سياره
الكهربائيه منذ الحاديه عشره والثانيه عشر
ظهرا من هذا اليوم حتى هذه اللحظه
الظلام دامس الشوارع شبه خاليه في هذه
المدن قلق وتوتر من المواطنين والان جراء
ما يحدث من اشتباكات والان نستمع الى هذه
الاصوات التي هي واضحه جدا ان هناك صعيد
واضح
طيب اخر التصريحات او يعني معلومات تنقل
واقع الامور في مقر الجيش السوداني محيطه
وايضا في بعض المرافق المهمه كيف تبدو ومن
يسيطر عليها
نعم بالنسبه للمناطق هناك تضارب في
الانبار فيما يتعلق بالمناطق التي يتم
السيطره عليها وهذا يدفعنا للحديث عن هذه
الاخبار بحساسيه عاليه جدا لان ياتي خبر
يؤكد خبر ينفي وتبقى الحقيقه ضايعه مع
وجودها لكن ما هو مؤكد ان هناك مناطق
حساسه يسيطر عليها الدعم السريع وهناك
مناطق ايضا حساسه سيطر عليه الدعم السريع
واستطاع الجيش السوداني ان يخرجه منها هذا
هو الواضح حتى هذه اللحظه لكن ليست هناك
معلومات دقيقه واضحه في هذا الموضوع سوى
بعض المناطق وهي محلوله جدا التي
تطابقت فيها الانباء بوجود مثلا قوات
الدعم السريع فيها الهيئه القوميه لدعم
التلفزيون كالقياده العامه للجيش السوداني
وبعض المناطق الاخرى وكذلك مطار معروي
الذي اكد مراسل العربيه
المقر القياده لهذا المقر تسيطر عليها
قوات الدعم السليم
انيه طبعا كلها تجلب وتدعو الطرفين الى
يعني ضبط النفس ووقف هذا القتال هل هناك
ما هو ابعد من ذلك اي تحركات جهود وساطه
تم الاعلان عنها او تجري وراء الكواليس
نعم بالنسبه للحديث عن تهدئه الاوضاع
والحوار رئاسه اركان القوات المسلحه
السودانيه ذكرت انه لا تفاوض ولا حوار قبل
حل وتفتيش ميليشيا حين بهذا الوقت حين
المتمرده هذا ما ذكرته رئاسه اركان القوات
المشتركه وهي تتحدث عن هذا الامر في او
هذا يدعو الى تصعيد واضح جدا في هذه اللغه
اللغه التصعيد ليست مقتصره على الجيش وحده
وكذلك الدعم السريع له نصيب كبير من هذا
الامر من لغه التصعيد كذلك بحديثه بعبارات
كثيره جدا وردد الكثير من العبارات تمس
قائد الجيش السوداني وتمس قيادات الجيش
السوداني وانها اليمن جعلت هذا التوتر يصل
الى هذا الحد وكانت شركه فيه بمشاركه ايضا
اتهامات نشر اتهامات قالتها قوات الدعم
السريعه على لساني قائدها وهي تقول ان هذه
المعركه او هذا التوتر الكبير وهذا الضرب
يقف من خلفه قيادات من الحركه الاسلاميه
التي كانت حاكمه في السابق وقد تمت
بالتحديد علي كارت احد القيادات الذي
كانوا موجودين في القياده في ذلك الوقت
طيب اذا ما زلنا معكم مشاهدينا في هذه
التغطيه المباشره لاحداث السودان دعونا
نستمع للصوت الطبيعي من هذه الصور من
الخرطوم
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا مع هذه الصور الحيه
من الخرطوم يبدو ان الاشتباكات تجددت ولكن
طبعا ما نراه هو محيط مقر قياده الجيش
ويبدو ان الاوضاع هادئه نوعا ما في محيط
المقر بعد ان تجددت الاشتباكات وتصاعدت في
وقت من الاوقات لاشتباكات عنيفه جدا
وسمع ذوي الرصاص والطلقات بشكل عالي جدا
وقريب من موقع الكاميرا على كل حال معنا
الان من الخرطوم الصحفي السياسي خالد
الفكي اهلا بك استاذ خالد مره اخرى معنا
استاذ خالد يعني من الواضح بان الامور
مرجحه للتصعيد زياده في العنف كيف ترى
يعني اتجاه الامور في الساعات القادمه
نعم يعني صحيح ان الاوضاع هي تبدو او
مرشحه للتصعيد ومحاوله كل الطرق على
السيطره وتحقيق النقاط على افضل الميدان
وذلك من خلال ما نسمعه من
الانفجارات
ومصاص بشكل كثيف وان كان متغطي فهذا يعني
يشير ويدلل على انه على افضل الميدان ربما
كانت هناك محاولات للكرور فرض ومحاولات
للسيطره على مواقع هنا وهناك او محاولات
بملاحظه كل طرف للتاني وقطع الطريق عليه
الان الشارع تكاد تكون خاليه يعني انا قبل
هذا المباشر
ذهبت
في مناطق غريبه
ويعني الناس الان
تقشيه الخروج وتغشيه
التجدد الصراع الدموي وسقوط الدهانات في
المنازل لان الان هناك حوادث غاده لقتل
عدد من المواطنين الابرياء برصاصات طائشه
فالمواطنين الان يخشون كلما حل الليل ان
تشتد هذه
الاشتباكات ويقدرون ان لا تفرق هذه
الدهانات وهذه المواصفات مكانها نعم اسمح
لي مشاهدينا فقط دعونا نستمع
للصوت الطبيعي على ما يبدو الاشتباكات
تتجدد الان في الخرطوم
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا مع هذه الصور من
الخرطوم الاشتباكات متقطعه اذا تدور الان
في مناطق مختلفه من الخرطوم اعود مره اخرى
لضيفي من هناك الصحفي والمسي خالد الفكي
استاذ خالد كنت قبل قليل تتحدث عن انه
يعني عدد كبير من المدنيين ايضا سقطوا
ضحايا وقتل من جراء هذه الاشتباكات برصاص
طائش
نقابه الاطباء السودانيين تتحدث عن ارتفاع
عدد القتلى الى سته وعشرين ما هو موقف
الشارع السوداني المواطنين السودانيين من
ما يجري
يبدو ان الشارع السوداني الان
هو يريد اناء هذه الحرب التي اندلعت بين
القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع الان هناك
مخاوف وخشيه من تمددها والدخولها الى
الاحياء
السكنيه لان الان هناك بعض المواقع
الاستراديه والعسكريه على مقربه من من
السكن المواطنين على سبيل المثال سلاح
المدرعات وفي منطقه الشجره جنوب الخرطوم
كذلك ايضا سلاح الذخيره هو في منطقه غريبه
من السكن المواطنين هناك ايضا تصنيع
الحربي في منطقه غريبه من المواطنين وهذه
المناطق سمعنا يعني
الرصاص
في محيطها فبالتالي هناك الخشيه والمخاوف
الان واضحه وبارزه في يعني التحول هذا
الامر وصبو
دهانات في المنازل والاحياء القريبه من
هذه المقر العسكريه الشارع السوداني الان
يبدو حذر جدا في التعامل والتعاطي في هذا
الامر ويريد حزمه بيدفع ويمكن يعني يقول
انه لا بد من الذهاب في اتجاه حجم هذا
الامر لصالح القوات المسلحه وان تكون كافه
القوى القوات هي منضويه تحت لواء القوات
المسلحه ولا تكون هناك اي قوات خارج سيطره
الدوله مما يعني يمهد لاشعه الفوضى واشاعه
مثل هذه الاعمال ومحاوله استغلال مثل هذه
القوات في اعمال يعني هي مخله بالسلامه
العامه مقله للامن العام في في البلاد
ولكن دعيني راويه اشير الى معلومه تحصلت
عليها قبل قليل لانه يعني قبل اقل من ساعه
كانت هناك اشتباكات في قريبه من
مقر العربيه الحدث وبعض المقر مقر بعض
الفضائيات في ابراج النيلين على حدود جسر
المسلميه بين القوات المسلحه وبين الدعم
السريع ربما هي محاولات
للدعم السريع للدخول الى
وسط الخرطوم حيث ان هذا الجزر هو يعني
رابط
جنوب القرطوم بوسطها ويقود في شارع متفرع
الى القياده العامه فبالتالي يعني ما
نسمعه من رصاص في في شاشه العربيه ربما
يكون مصدره تبادل تبادل هذا هذه
الاشتباكات بالاخص ومحاولات الدفاع او
محاولات الكرب والفرع وربما يعني احد
الزملاء يعني نجا من من من من طلقه طائشه
احد الاعلاميين يعني كانت قريبه منه ولكن
الحمد لله رب العالمين فاذا الاوضاع مرشحه
للتوتر والتصاعد ومحاوله اي طرف للسيطره
في ظل معرفه ما يمكن ان نسميها بكسر
العظام راويه
طيب ذكرت قبل قليل استاذ خالد بانه يعني
الجيش السوداني يسعى لحسم هذه المعركه
ويرى بانه جميع القوات العسكريه يجب ان
تكون منضويه تحت الجيش هل برايك هي تعول
على العمليه عمليه المسح الجوي التي تحدث
عنها وهي مرتقبه ربما في الساعات القادمه
عمليه مسح جوي لمواقع قوات الدعم السريع
هل تعول عليها في حسم هذه المعركه برايك
نعم نعم يعني اعتقد انه منذ الصباح او منذ
انطلاق هذه العمليات القوات المسلحه يعني
دفعت بسلاح الجو
لضربي عدد من المواقع للدعم السريع
معسكرات في اطراف العاصمه وضعت فيها
القوات الدعم السريع وربما قبل قليل
القوات المسلحه اصدرت التمويه للمواطنين
بانها يعني بان الحربي سيجري مساحات واسعه
ودقيقه على كافه المواقع التي يعني يحتمل
فيها وجود لقوات الدعم السريع فبالتالي
هذا التنبيه يشير الى ان ربما القادم
المسلحه ومع دخول الفجر تكون هي غد غضب
بشكل كبير على مقار ومناطق تواجد هذه
القوات وايضا يعني دون شك هذا اصحابه يعني
تحرك على على
الميدان سواء كان من خلال المدرعات او من
خلال اسلحه متخصصه كالمظلات او وحدات اخرى
لها القدره على الالتحام والسيطره في
الميدان فبالتالي الاوضاع هي الان تشير
اشاره واضحه ان هناك تكتيك وخطه عسكريه
يعني رغبه من القوات المسلحه لحسم هذا
الامر لانها هي وصفت الدعم السريع بالقوه
المتمرده وان اركان الجيش قالت انه لا
حوار لا تفاوض قبل القضاء على ما يقوم به
الدعم السريع من ماده بالتفلتات
خالد ساعود لك بعد قليل مشاهدينا معنا من
لندن الكاتب الصحفي خالد
الاعسر
اذا اهلا بك استاذ خالد هل تسمعني
نعم اهلا بك اهلا بكم بمشاهدكم الكرام يا
استاذ خالد ما هي قراءتك لهذا المشهد والى
اين تتجه الامور
التحيه لك ولمشاهدكم الكرام الواقع ان
التصريح الذي
خرج من الجيش انه بصدد حسم هذا التفلت قبل
اجراء اي عمليه التفاوض او شيء اي شيء من
شانه وقف يطلع النار هذا ينوم عن ان
المؤسسه العسكريه كما تفضل ضيفك من
الخرطوم تعمل رؤيه وتكتيك محدد حسب
المعلومات المتوفره
وبكل تاكيد هناك العسكريين يعلمون ان قطع
خطوط الامداد على القوه المهاجمه لقوات
القوات المسلحه التي هي تدافع عن ماكينه
يؤكد ان يعني من الممكن ان تخلص او تكمل
الذخيره التي تستعين بها القوات المهاجمه
من الدعم السريع وفي ظل انقطاع خطوط
الامداد هذا بالتاكيد ينتهي الى اجيال
زمنيه ربما تاخذ بعض الوقت
في مقرها وفي اماكن تواجدها
هو بالتاكيد تم تعطيل هيئه القياده وضرب
عدد من مغارات الدعم السريع خارج الخرطوم
في الجيلي في الطيف والحسنات في عدد من
المواقع هي حيدت كثير من الفاعليه التي
كان يمكن ان تكون عليها قوات الدعم السريع
ولكن هذا الامر نحن بصدد ارسال رسائل
تطمينيه ودعوات لكي يغلب الناس صوت العقل
ليس بالضرور هذه المعركه ليس فيها كاس
وانما الخاسر هو الشعب السوداني وهؤلاء
الذين يتغاتلونهم ابناء وطن واحد وابناء
مؤسسه واحده بكل
تاكيد ولكن من الواضح بانه للجيش
نيه بالفعل لحسم هذه
المعركه
مشاهدينا نذكركم باننا ما زلنا مع هذه
الصور
المتنوعه لاحداث هذا اليوم
منها ما هو مباشر وحي الان للوضع في
الخرطوم
وايضا صور سابقه
للاشتباكات خلال هذا اليوم طيب استاذ خالد
هل مازال هناك هامش للبساطه قبل ان تنفجر
الامور على الارض اكثر من هذا
في السلطه والوصول الى مكاذب سياسيه مبنيه
على فكره الاتفاق الاطار الذي كان يمكن ان
يتطور الى اتفاق سياسي وفق شراكه وتبادل
مصالح بين القوى المدنيه التي اختارت ان
تعسكر عمليه الانتقال المدني الديمقراطي
السلس وحاولت ان تصنع زراعه عسكريا بتوسيع
شقه الخلاف والهوى بين القوات الدعم
السريعيه العسكري
العنيف هل يعني ما زال هناك فرصه او مجال
لرايب الصدع بعد هذا اليوم
يعني العوده الى الاتفاق الايطالي ودمج
قوات الدعم السريع بغض النظر عن الاطار
الزمني المختلف عليه في قوات الجيش
وبكل تاكيد كل الحروب تنتهي الى تفاوض حتى
في الحروب بين الدول
وليس ببعيد ان تكون هناك فرصه لحسم هذا
الملف وايقاف نزيف الدم بين القوات
المتقاتله الان لا سيما وانهم جميعا اصحاب
اهم وطني واحد ولكن الذي لا يمكن ان يعول
عليه من جديد هو فكره الاتفاق الايطالي
الاتفاق الايطالي هو الذي اجعل فتيل
الازمه هو الذي لهب هذا الموقف واوصل
المكون العسكري الى هذا النوع من الصراع
والاتفاق الايطالي هو الذي افضى الى صراع
المكونات المدنيه وانسحاب هو فاعله كما هو
حال لجان المقاومه وحزب البعث العربي
الاشتراكي والحزب الشيوعي هذه مكونات
فاعله واساسيه في عمليه التغيير والثوره
لكنها خرجت في 6 ابريل ترفض فكره الاتفاق
الايطالي بشكل كلي لا ترفض فقط قضيه سيطره
المدنيين على يعني فكره الاتفاق للطال
وانما المكونين معا المدني والعسكري
وبالتالي في
المعقده والازمه الحقيقيه كانت تكمن في
نصوص الاتفاق الايطالي الذي تمت فيه شراكه
غير معلنه بين مكونات مدنيه ارادت ان تخلق
قاعده عسكريه تحتمي بها خلال فتره عشره
اعوام وهي تدعو الى قيام نظام ديمقراطي
كيف يمكن ان يقوم نظام ديمقراطي في ظل
وجود قوات عسكريه خارج مظله الجيش الوطني
الواحد هذا يتعارض كثيرا مع فكره الانتقال
السلس وحتى فكره عسكره الدوله من خلال
زراعه عسكري هي تتعارض مع فكره الانتقال
المدني والديمقراطي وحتى القيام انتخابات
حره ونزيهه وشفافه باعتبار ان وجود عسكريه
فاعله بكل هذه الامكانيات خارج مظله الجيش
الوطني الوعد هذا بالتاكيد يتعارض مع كل
القيم الديمقرا طيه طيب ولكن استاذ خالد
يعني فيما يتعلق على الاقل حل حالات هذه
الازمه على الصعيد الميداني الان هناك
جهود عربيه ودعوات لاجتماع للجامعه
العربيه لمناقشه السودان ايضا مجلس الامن
من المفترض ان يجتمع لمناقشه هذه الازمه
يوم الاثنين هل باعتقادك مثل هذه الضغوط
عربيا او دوليا يمكن ان تجدي نفعا
انا في تقدير ان الوساطه الحميده مطلوبه
ولكن الواضح ان الاصرار من قوات الدعم
السريع بارتكاب هذه الخطيئه انا اسميها
خطيئه لانه التسويق الاعلامي الذي تم
لفكره وصول هذه القوات الى مروي في بيان
الدعم السريع الاول الذي اكد ان هذا الامر
تم
بالتنسيق العسكريه
بينما خرج بيان من الجيش
انفجارات على ما يبدو في العاصمه الخرطوم
دعونا نستمع بعض الشيء للصوت الطبيعي
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا معكم مع هذه الصور
الحيه من الخرطوم تجدد الاشتباكات وسماع
ذوي اطلاق نار كثيف وانجارات والمحيط مقر
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم
اعود مره اخرى
لضيفي من هناك خالد الفكري استاذ خالد هل
لديك اي معلومات عامه يجري على ما يبدو
هناك تصاعد في الاشتباكات والحجرات ايضا
نعم نعم راويه اعتقد بان الامور تزداد
تعديل تزداد سوء
وربما يعني كل ما اوغل الليل يعني
الاوضاع تشهد تدهور وبشكل
مؤسف جدا يعني الان لا يستطيع احد ان
يتكهن
بالاوضاع بدقه لان المعلومات صعب الحصول
عليها في ظل عدم قدرتنا على التواصل
والوصول الى مناطق الاحداث
الخرطوم الان هي مسلوله وعباره عن سكن
عسكريه انتشار للمدرعات والاليات الصغيره
والمدفعيه الصغيره
الرصاص بكثافه مما يعني بان الان هناك
معرفه
المنطقه التي تشهد هذه الاشتباكات هل
نتحدث عن محيط مقر الق ياده العامه هناك
ايضا مناطق اخرى تشهد
اشتباكات مماثله
نعم نعم يعني انا المعلومات التي توفرت
لدي ان ما يجري هو الان في محيط القياده
العامه
ومحاوله السيطره عليها
واغلاقها تماما من بين الجيش والدعم
السريع ربما هناك ما زالت بعض الجيوب
للدعم السريع تحاول ايضا
ان
تجد ثغرات في الدخول الى محيط القياده او
الى محيط المقر الرئيسيه في وسط الخرطوم
والجيش الان يعني على حسب المعلومات
المتوفره لدي هو ينشر اليات الثقيله ويغلق
الطرق المؤديه الى كافه المرافق الحيويه
ويتم تبادل اطلاق الذخيره الصغيره
والالياء
والمدفعيه الصغيره في المحيط
هذه مناطق المرافق الاستراتيجيه بل الان
علمت ان هناك ايضا تبادل لاطلاق الرصاص في
غرب جنوب العاصمه في مناطق صالحه ومناطق
الفتيحاب وهي يعني كانت في هذه المنطقه
كانت هناك معسكر للدعم السريع وجهت له
ضربه صباح اليوم من قبل الطيران الحربي
ربما ايضا بعض الجيوب من الدعم السريعي هي
تحاول التسلل والدخول الى ام درمان
ومحاوله محاسبه بعض المراتب العسكريه في
في ام درمان وكان السلاح المهندسين او او
بعض الاسلحه الاخرى راجمات او خلافه من
المناطق العسكريه الحيويه او السلاح الطبي
فبالتالي كما قلت اليك انه كلما اوقل
الليل ربما نسمع استداد هذه هذه الذخيره
والدانات ويعني يعني يصب علي
تعرف التكهم بمعلومات يعني اكثر دقه حول
التحركات والمصادر التي يمكن لان حتى هذه
اللحظه هناك في المعلومات ونحاول ان
نتواصل مع بعض الزملاء في بعض المناطق هنا
وهناك من الزملاء الصحفيين ومعارفنا حتى
نتحصل على معلومات بشان ما يجري على افضل
البلدان ويعطينا الاوضاع معقده ومرشحه
لمزيد من التصعيد والتوتر خاصه ان سلاح
الطيران او الجيش اعلم بان سلاح الطيران
هو رافت الاستعداد لجراء مسحي واسع لمواقع
الدعم السريع وملاحقته على الضلع
الميلان فالامور المعقده جدا طيب ابقى معي
يا استاذ خالد سعود لك بعد قليل مشاهدينا
نذكركم باننا ما ز لنا نتعا هذه الصور
الحيه والمباشره من محيط مقر قياده الجيش
السوداني في الخرطوم وقد سمع دوي اطلاق
نار كثيف في محيط المقر في الخرطوم قبل
قليل قلنا كنا نستمع لهذه الاصوات اصوات
الطلقات
المتفرقه اذا تجدد الاشتباكات في مناطق
مختلفه لاسيما في محيط مقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم
مشاهدينا بعد الانتفاضه الشعبيه التي
اطاحت في ابريل عام 2019 بحكميه عمر حسن
البشير بدا السودانيون مسيره التحول الى
الديمقراطيه لكن عراقيل مختلفه وقفت في
الطريق في ظل صراع المحتدم على السلطه في
هذا البلد
السودان رحله شاقه من البحث عن الحريه
والديمقراطيه حكايه طويله لم تكتب لها
نهايه سعيده حتى الان
الان من ذلك ان هذا البلد العربي
والافريقي انزلق نحو القتال بدل لغه
السلام والحوار
التحول نحو الحكم المستقر مثل شعله امل
حين تمت الاطاحه بنظام البشير عقب انتفاضه
شعبيه في ربيع العام 2019 في اغسطس من
السنه ذاتها وافق الجيش على تقاسم السلطه
مع المدنيين ريثما يتم اجراء انتخابات لكن
الترتيب تعطل وسرعان من قلب على ما التزم
به الزي العسكري في السودان وكحال اغلب
بلدان الجنوب يشكل قوه مهيمنه منذ
استقلاله عام
1956 اذ خاض حروبا داخليه وقام بانقلابات
متكرره ولديه حيازات اقتصاديه ضخمه حظي
الجيش بدعم داخلي من فصائل متمرده استفادت
من اتفاق السلام في 2020 ومن المخضرمين في
حكومه البشير الذين عادوا الى الخدمه
المدنيه الصراع بين قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
الب به محمد حمدان دقلو يوازيه صراع اخر
مع المدنيين الذين يضغطون من اجل الرقابه
على الجيش ودمج قوات الدعم السريع شبه
العسكريه التي لها وضع قوي في الجيش
النظامي امر اخر يدخل في المعادله السودان
موجود في منطقه مضطربه يحدها البحر الاحمر
ومنطقه الساحل والقرن الافريقي استقطب
موقعه الاستراتيجي وثرواته الزراعيه قوى
مختلفه ما ادى الى تعقيد فرص نجاح
الانتقال وها هو الان في طريق حرب اهليه
ستعيده سنوات الى الوراء بلال الوجداني
العربيه
اود مشاهدينا الى مراسله العربيه سالم
الهاشمي في
سالم اهلا بك مره اخرى ما الجديد لديك على
ما يبدو تجددت الاشتباكات وسمعنا اطلاق
نار كثيف في محيط مقر
الجيش السوداني
مره اخرى في مقر قياده الجيش السوداني هذه
الاشتباكات جاءت بالتزامن مع
مروحيات بدات اشوف ايضا العاصمه
الخرطوم العالي ومع هذا الكثير لاطلاق
العديد من المروحيات المستمع اليها بين
الحين والاخرى تجوب في اجواء الخطوط
هذه هي اخر المشكله بالذات ما زال الوضع
كما هو عليه
في العاصمه الخرطوم من
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي حتى اللحظه
توتر القلق الذي يسود المواطنين حتى هذه
اللحظات
في انتظار جديد ثم يتعلق بهذه الازمه
الحقيقيه في داخل العاصمه الخرطوم
طيب تحدثت عن انه في مروحيات الان تجوب او
في اجواء الخرطوم يعني في اي مناطق بالضبط
وهل هذا انذار ربما ببدء المسح الجوي
للجيش المرتقب
نعم بكل تاكيد ايضا هناك
المسلحه تحدث على ان الجيش استولى على
جميع مقرات القوات الدعم السريه في ام
درمان حيث قالت هذا العامه للقوات المسلحه
ان القوات المسلحه استولت على جميع مقرات
قوات الدعم
السريعتها واسلحتها التي خلفها وراءهم
اثناء هروبهم من هذه المواقع هذه هي اخر
الانباء الذين
طيب سنكون معك في حال جد اي جديد سالم
اذا
مشاهدينا نذكركم
ما زلنا مع هذه المشاهد لتجدد الاشتباكات
ما بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني في مقر قياده الجيش في
الخرطوم مراسل العربيه كان ذكر قبل قليل
بانه انقطاع الماء والكهرباء في عده مناطق
بالخرطوم جراء الاشتباكات التيار
الكهربائي قطع في وقت مبكر من هذا اليوم
عاد لمناطق قليله من العاصمه
وايضا مدن اخرى ولكن يعني هذه عوده جزئيه
اغلب المناطق ما زالت ايضا يعني تعاني من
انقطاع الكهرباء
والماء في هذه الاثناء
معنا الان من الخرطوم شاب ابراهيم الطيب
الناطق الرسمي باسمي حزب التحالف الوطني
السوداني اهلا بك استاذ شهاب معنا استاذ
شهاب قراءتك للمشهد وموقف حزب التحالف
الوطني مما يجري
السلام عليكم اولا يعني
نترحم على ارواح الضحايا الذين سقطوا
اليوم نتيجه
لهذه
المواجهه التي تمت ما بين الجيش والدعم
السريع ونعتقد انه
يعتبر انقلاب لادوار
المؤسسات العسكريه والامنيه في في وظيفتها
بحيث ان هي يفترض انه احافظ على ارواح
هؤلاء المواطنين ومن ثم
يعني توفر لهم الطمانينه والامس لكن الان
ما نشاهده هو صراع يعني افقد
البعض ارواح بريئه وايضا يروع
المواطنين ما ندعو له هو ان تتم يتم يتم
وقف طير مشروط لهذه الحرب العباسيه
المواجهه الدمويه بين القوتين ونعتقد انه
المدخل الصحيح لحل هذا
لهذه الازمه هو قطع الطريق امام النظام
البيض الذي عمل طيله الفطره الماضيه لخلق
اي شكل من المواجهه ما بين الدعم السريع
وبعدين القوات المسلحه
المشهد يتجه الى يعني ما هو عكس ذلك تماما
طبيعي انه
انه ابتدت
احنا الحزرنا منه كثير انه الصراع العسكري
العسكري حتما ممكن يؤدي الى
المواجهه المسلحه وده برضو ممكن يعني يقود
في فتره من الفترات
يعني للانزلاق اتجاه صراع الجماعي ايضا
وحاله من الاستقطاب
شاب يسمح لي فقط اريد ان اذكر المشاهدين
ببعض الاخبار العاجله التي تردنا الان
تقول بان طيران الحربي السوداني يقصف
معسكر الدعم السريع الضخم بمنطقه صالحه
بام درمان اذا على ما يبدو بدء القصف
الجوي والمسح الجوي التي تحدث العمليه
التي تحدث عنها الجيش السوداني حيث يقوم
او قام الطيران الحربيه السودانيه بقصف
معسكر الدعم السريع الضخم بمنطقه صالحه
بام تورمان نعود مره اخرى لضيفنا في
الخرطوم استاذ شهاب ابراهيم الطيب استاذ
شهاب لنفهم بس الموضوع ميدانيا وعسكريا
معروف يعني باي حرب من لديه ربما التفوق
الجوي قد يكون اكثر قدره على حسم المعركه
فهل نتحدث هنا عن حسم جوي لهذه المعركه
لصالح الجيش
وطبعا باي حال من الاحوال انا اتحدث
كسياسي مؤكد وانت تعلمين وليس كخبير [__]
يعني عسكريه ما
انه هو في كل الاحوال هذه الحرب تدور الان
ليس فيها رابح الخاسر هو
السودان لانه نحن نعتقد انه الازمه في 25
اكتوبر هي قبض على على
الفكره الانتقاليه
يمكن تحققت يعني بعد تضحيات كبيره الان
نحن بنزيد في يعني في كلفه الدم اتجاه اي
شكل بتحقيق واضح جدا انه مهما كان
هنالك يعني التفوق لطرف على الاخر هو في
الاخر البدع الثمن المواطنين الابرياء
وحتى المؤسسات العسكريه الان هي بتدفع ثمن
سوداني سودانيين كان ان تحقن من خلال
عمليه سياسيه ونعتقد انه ده كان ادوار
السياسيه في
استطاعوا انه يقللوا من حده المواجهه في
اوقات كثيره لكن في الاخر كان الواقع يعني
اوصلنا
للمرحله دي لكن في اعتقادنا هذه الحرب
الجميع خاسر فيها لانه كان يمكن ان تتم
يتم التوصل للجيش واحد مهني تحت قياده
وسيطره واحده بتكلفه لا يعني اقل بكثير
مما الان اذا كان تم التنازلات وكان هنالك
اراده فعلا للمؤسستين العسكريتين انهم
يخرجوا من التاثير على العمليه السياسيه
الان هم شكوا الواقع جديد هذا الواقع لا
يتجاوز الحل السياسي فهي حال من الاحوال
لكن
التركيز الان على ما هو عسكري على ما يبدو
استاذ شهاب الطرفان صرح بانه لا حوار في
هذه المرحله رغم تثمينهم للجهود جهود
الوساطه كافه هل مازال هناك برايك هامش
لهذه الجهود
لتدارك ما هو اسوا
يظل هنالك يعني متسع وليس هامش
لوقف هذا الاقتتال اذا كانت القوه
العسكريه لها اراده حقيقيه لكن من خلال ما
نسمعه من تصريحات وبيانات
هي دي
محاوله لانه كل طرف يحاول انه يتفوق في
هذه المواجهه ليحسن من مواقفه تجاه
اللي هو يعني اي شكل من اشكال التفاوض
القادمه باي حال من الاحوال المساحه ممكن
تتوفر انه يتم وقف
لتبادل هذه
لاطلاق النار دون شروط
والعوده
لطاوله المفاوضات من خلال
جميع المبادرات الحريه والتغيير حسب علمي
تحاول ان تبذل مجهود حتى الان من خلال
تواصله مع بعض الاطراف العسكريه
الان هي اطراف المواجهه بالقوه مع اطراف
اقليميه ودوليه لانه يتم وقف
المواجهه العسكريه يعني في اقرب
فرصه في التالي اللي هي انا اتحدث عن هذه
المساحه اذا كان يمكن ان يستجيب الاطراف
لاي شكله والا نحن ممكن يعني نمشي لابعد
لانه في الاخره
ما في حرب بتحسم يعني
ما بين يوم وليله
استمرار الحرب ويمكن ان احنا في السودان
عندما تجربه
يعني مريره في حرب الجنوب سواء كان الحرب
في دارفور
حتى حتى اذا كان هنالك جيش نظامي يملك
يملك السلاح هنالك تكلفه كبيره جدا
يعني طيب استاذ شهاب ساعود لك بعد قليل
اعود مره اخرى لضيفه في لندن الكاتب
الصحفي خالد العيسير استاذ خالد يعني
الجميع يتحدث ويقول بانه لا يعني منتصر في
هذه الحرب ولكن على الارض ميدانيا يبدو
انه يعني اليد العليا هي للجيش على الاقل
مما نسمع من انباء
يعني تصريحات هل ينتظر حسم هذه المعركه
قريبا عسكريا من خلال هذه المعطيات
بالتاكيد الذي سوق فكره ان قوات الدعم
السريعه او اي قوات اخرى قادره على
انتاجهم جيش
بحاله جيش السوداني الذي هو عمره شرف ان
يتم ان يكمل 100 عام هو صاحب غرض اوقع
ولكن
الجميع بانها لا يستهان بها يعني اعداد
ضخمه وسلاح
وتجهيزات يعني نوعا ما يعني قوه قريبه الى
قوه الجيش ام تقول بان ذلك ليس صحيحا
لا اريد ان اظلم قوات الدعم السريع لما
كان لها من اسهامات فيه على الصعيد الوطني
والعباد ادوار محوريه لكن الواقع المشهود
بموجب المعطيات انها تشكل وحده من وحدات
الجيش وعندما نتحدث عن الجيش نتحدث عن
مدفعيه وطيران وبحريه
وهجانه
وطيران يعني لا توجد مقارنه على الاطلاق
اذا الذي دفع قوات الدعم السريعه التي هي
اصلا جزء من الجيش هذا يعني نحن نتحدث
بصراحه العباره كالعاده يعني وحتى الاخ
شهاب الذي يتحدث الان هو احد رموز هو
الحريه والتغيير التي وقعت البلاد في هذه
المعركه
وشاهدت وهو موجود على الهواء لو لم يكن
موجودا لما فتحت هذا النقاش لكن شاهدته في
عشرات المرات خلال السته اشهر الماضيه وهو
يكافح وينافع ويستميل في قوات الدعم
السريع بخطابات تمثل الجسم الذي يمثل
ممثلا في غوار الحريه والتغيير المجلس
المركزي هم هؤلاء هم الذين ادخلوا السودان
في هذا النفق المسلم هؤلاء هم الذين وقعوا
قوات الدعم السريع وقيادتها في هذا الفخ
الذي وضع في مواجهه مباشره مع الجيش
الوطني السوداني هؤلاء هم الذين لم
يستصحبوا في بالهم مصالح الامه السودانيه
وبذلك استطاعوا ان يعملوا يقيموا اختراقات
لاستقطاب بعض الهوى العسكريه وممثله في
الدعم السريع وقدموا لها واغضبوا عليها
بالعود لكي تكون قوه منفصله من الجيش لا
بل لكي تكون اساس الجيش ويندمج فيها الجيش
الوطني السوداني بكل مكوناته هؤلاء يجب ان
يتوقفوا من الخطاب السابق ويفتح صفحه
جديده ويضربوا باتفاهم الاطار عرض الحائط
ويفتح صفحه جديده بعقليات جديده لا تتحدث
عن
عن مصالحه وطنيه شامله لا تستثني الا
الذين جرهم القانون من اتباع النظام
السابق ولكن هذا الخطاب واوصر السودان الى
هذا الى هذه الدرجه من المواجهه انا اتحدث
معك بسرع عباره نحن نقدم خطاب وطني يطالب
الجميع الدعم السريع الجيش كل المكونات
العسكريه ان توقف الختان لاننا نرى فيهم
جميعا ابناء وطن واحد اصحاب قضيه واحده
ولكن دخل عليهم بعد الساسه الذين هم الذين
اختلفوا على العديد من الخروقات التي
ارتكبتها المؤسسه العسكريه على مر التاريخ
في انقلابات عسكريه مؤدلجه كانت هي التي
تحركا القوات المسلحه وليس العكس وبالتالي
نحن الان في محطه مفصليه من التاريخ يجب
ان نسمي الاشياء المسمياتها وعلى الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي على وجه الخصوص
ان تستغفر وتتوب وتعتذر للشعب السوداني ان
ارتكبت هذا الجرم الكبير ان اشعلت فتيلا
النيران بين المكون العسكري كما جعلت
النيران في نفسها
عنها الكثير من المكونات طيب استاذ خالد
دعنا نستمع الى رد استاذ شهاب استاذ شهاب
هل المنزل تبعنا نعم انا معكم كيف تردون
على ما قاله استاذ خالد
لانه في كلام خطير
انا ما حابه انه الامور لكن باكد لاستاذ
خالد انه انا ما من السياسيين الممكن يتم
تصنيفهم في وقت زي ده عشان
تهديد مبطنه انه انا انحاز لطرف عسكري
عشان ما يعبر على شهاب ابراهيم الطيب بانه
انا مقاتل
ويمكن الحزب الانتمله وكان حزب له خلفيه
نضاليه محدده لا يمكن ان يتم
ارسال رسائل مبطنه لكن لطالما انه هو
اتحدث عن انه لا بد من ان نسمي الاشياء
بمسمياتها هذه الواجهات التي
في الاعلام هي من اسكت روح يعني المواجهه
ما بين الدعم السريع والقوات المسلحه في
طيله الفتره الفاتت وانا ما حرص انه اتابع
خالد العيسر لكن هو واضح تماما من حديثه
من من فتره انه هو برضه بنفس منطقه
التصنيف هو يصنف انه هو يدعم
المؤتمر الوطني واجهته من خلال الحديث عن
انه هنالك حرب يا سيدي نحن ذهبنا لابعد من
كذا موقف استراتيجي مدعوم دوليا واقليميا
ومبزول في وثائق يعني اخرجت الحريه
والتغيير ونحن ندعم هذه الوثائق لانه انا
كنا جزء منها انه لا بد من ان يتم تشكيل
جيش واحد مهني بقياده واحده تستطيع انها
تسيطر على تسلسل التعليمات لهذه الجيوش
ونحن في واقع في السياسيين بنتعامل مع
واقع يحتوي على اكثر من ثمانيه جيوش بخلاف
قوات الدعم السريع والقوات المسلحه
بالتالي يمكن الاستفاده الاطاري مش في
مضمونه وفي صريح
الفقرات الموجوده فيه يتحدث عن تشكيل جيش
واحد ويمكن ما وصلت له الورشه يمكن
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري انه يتم دمج
الدعم السريع داخل القوات المسلحه لاننا
نحن نعرف يعني المؤسسه العسكريه والرسوخه
ويمكن ده ما مساله كمان لانه برضو انا حزب
التحالف الوطني السوداني ويحوي من من
قاعده القوات المسلحه
العسكريه اللي بتشكل قيادته نحن نحترم هذه
المؤسسه ونعي دورها لكن
اسطيله الثلاثين سنه الماضيه تم تخريب
لهذه القوات
المسلحه كان لابد من
ناتج من سلوك النظام المضاد هو هو الدعم
السريع وهو القرن وجودها سواء كانت كقوه
نظاميه او كماليشيا ويمكن كان واضح جدا من
حديث الرئيس
الساقط عمر البشير عندما كان يتحدث انه
حمايه حمايتي وليس حمايتي انا اطلق عليه
هي دي مساله واضح جدا انه نحن بنتعامل عن
واقع لم نصنعه الواقع ده ولكن قوات الدعم
السريع بعد الثوره يعني شوهد لها بمواقف
وطنيه كبيره
ولا تستطيع ان نحول هذه المواقف لشهادات
ادانه لقوات الدعم السريع لطالما انها هي
التزمت من خلال التفاهم بانه يتم دمجها
داخل القوات المسلحه ولم يتحدث الاخرين
عندما تحدثت قوى الحريه والتغيير
ومكوناتها بضروره ان يتشكل جيش واحد
بعقيده واحده وبقياده واحده جيش احترافي
مهني يلتزم بمهامه المنصوص فيها في
الدستور لذلك لا الحديث عن انه
الحل السياسي والاتفاق الاطاري هو من من
ادى الى الى الى الى هذا الحرب ذاك الاب
غير صحيح فضول النظام السابق وتصيرين من
يتحدثون في الاعلام كواجهات لهذه لهذا
التيار هم من دفع
ويجتهد في ان يسوق لفكره انه الاتفاق
الايطالي هو من من من اشعل الفتنه ابدا
الاستفاده الايطالي
وج في مرحله نقاش وموضوع توحيد قياده
واحده لهذه القوات ويمكن الكلام ده مبذول
في الاعلام وكان تتابع كثير من من الجهات
والراي العام عليم بذلك يبقى الجهات اللي
بيتحدث
هذه الساعه سنكون طبعا معكم مشاهدينا ربما
مع ضيوفنا ومراسلنا في هذه التغطيه
المستمره اشكر
الخرطوم واشكر ايضا ضيوفي من لندن كان معي
الصحفي خالد العيسى هذه تغطيه مستمره معكم
مشاهدينا اذا لاحداث السودان مباشره الان
الى زميلي صهيب سيكون معكم في الساعه
التاليه الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات